في الدوحه اختتم الرئيس التركي رج طيب
اردوغان جولته الخليجيه التي قادته ايضا
الى السعوديه والكويت وبحث اردوغان مع
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين
وتطورات الازمه الخليجيه وافاق حلها
بالحوار والطرق
الدبلوماسيه وفي تصريحات للجزيره قال وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود تشويش اوغلو ان
موقف بلاده من الازمه الخليجيه يقوم على
ضروره رفع الحصار اولا عن قطر قبل مناقشه
اي مطالب ياتي ذلك في وقت تتوالى فيه
المواقف الدوليه المرحبه بدعوه امير قطر
الى حوار لحل الازمه الخليجيه على قاعده
صون السياده الوطنيه ومن دون اي املاءات
تقرير فوزي بشرى في
الموضوع رفع الحصار اولا عن قطر ثم مناقشه
كل القضايا بين اطراف الازمه في الخليج
انه الموقف الذي حمله الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في مساع تعضد المبادره
الكويتيه لحل الازمه بين قطر وبين الثلاث
من دول الخليج هي السعوديه والامارات
والبحرين بدا اردوغان جولته بزياره
للسعوديه وهي الدوله التي نهضت بمهمه حصار
قطر بريا عبر منفذ سلوى الحدودي فاوقفت كل
واردات قطر من الاغذيه ثم تعاونت السعوديه
مع الامارات والبحرين على اطباق حصار جوي
على الدوحه كان اردوغان قد ذكر السعوديه
قبيل بدء جولته بان العالم الاسلامي بحاجه
الى التعاون والتضامن وليس الى انقسامات
جديده لا احد يعلم كم وقع في وجدان
السعوديه من معنى الايه الحاض على التعاون
على البر لا على الاثم والعدوان وهي التي
تمثلها اردوغان في نصحه اكثر من ذلك لا
احد يعلم اذا كانت السعوديه قد تاملت بين
يدي زياره اردوغان في مستويات الصراع الذي
تعيشه المنطقه السعوديه ينظر اليها على
انها مركز العالم الاسلامي بضمها اقدس
مقدساته حيث مكه والمدينه وهما الحرمان
اللذان اتخذ من خدمتهما الملك السعودي
لقبا له وربما لا شيء اعثر على المرء
والحال كذلك من تصور ان ما يحدث من حصار
لدوله مسلمه هو تمثل لقيم دين الحرمين في
تجويع المسلم واسلامه الى عدوه وليس العدو
في نظر السعوديه احدا غير ايران فالسعوديه
تجوع قطر بالحصار ثم تؤاخذ على انفتاحها
على طهر
وكل ذلك ناجم من جراء ان الحصار فعل غلبت
عليه نوازع السيطره وقل فيه حساب العواقب
يقسم الخطاب الديني السعودي العالم
الاسلامي الى سني وشيعي السعوديه مركز
السني وايران مركز الشيعي بكل حمولات هذا
التقسيم السياسيه ووفقا لهذا التقسيم لا
يستطيع اي تفكير استراتيجي اخراج تركيا من
المعادله المذهبيه التي يصار بين الحين
والاخر الى توظيفها في السياسه ولو صحت
مقوله المعسكر السني وهي بعض خطاب
السعوديه لما كان لطلب اغلاق القاعده
العسكريه التركيه في قطر من معنى ولربما
كان اولى ان يكون الطلب اغلاق قاعده
العداد العسكريه الامريكيه وفقا لقاعده
الولاء والبراء كما يفهمها اهل السنه
والجماعه هل وقع هذا الحساب في زياره
اردوغان الى السعوديه هل اكتشفت السعوديه
ان حصار قطر هو اضعاف للمعسكر السني
وتقويه للخصم الايراني وفق توصيفها
المذهبي اخطر ما في موضوع حصار قطر من قبل
الدول الخليجيه الثلاث وتابعها انها لا
تقوي خصمها الايراني الشيعي فحسب بل تعمد
بعلم او بجهل الى اضعاف المعسكر السني
الذي يضم دول الحصار
وتابعيها وتضرب اكثر مكوناته تجانسا وهي
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
ستكشف الايام المقبله حظ الجهد التركي من
النجاح ومقدار تقويته وتعزيزه لجهود امير
الكويت التي بدات مع بدء الازمه لكن شواهد
الازمه وحسابات الضالعين فيها تشير الى ان
تقسيم العالم الى اسلامي وغير اسلامي ثم
تقسيم الاسلامي الى سني وشيعي ثم تفتيت
السني الى دول تحب السلام والسعاده واخرى
تحب الارهاب وتموله لا يعدو ان يكون في
تقدير المراقبين غير واجهات مظلله عن
مشاريع
اخرى ثمت نزوع ذو نفس امبراطوري يقول
المراقبون تقف وراءه الامارات وتوظف فيه
السعوديه وتحاول استماله السودان بعد ان
حولت فيه مصر تحت ضائقه واقعها الاقتصادي
الى منصه انطلاق للسيطره على ليبيا عبر
الجنرال حفتر مشروع يمتد من بحر العرب الى
البحر الابيض المتوسط هل في وزع
الدبلوماسيه التركيه والكويتيه كبح جماح
هذا المشروع وبيان ما فيه من
مخاطر اولها خلخله التوازنات السياسيه
والمجتمعيه في الخليج وانشاء فراغات فيه
لن يملاها الهواء بل الطامحون من كل مله
ونحله انضم الينا هنا في الاستديو الدكتور
نايف بنهار الاستاذ في جامعه قطر وايضا
ينضم الينا من انقره شعبان قردش رئيس مركز
الشرق الاوسط للدراسات اهلا بكما وابدا
معك دكتور الى ما افضت باعتقادك باعتقادك
جوله اردوغان يعني هي زياره الرئيس
اردوغان
للخليج لم تاتي في اطار وساطه جديده او
اطار وساطه موازيه للوساطه الكويتيه وانما
جاءت في اطار تفعيل الوساطه الكويتيه في
اعتقادي ان تركيا معنيه يعني هي اكثر دوله
غير خليجيه معنيه بالازمه الخليجيه لانها
استهدفت بشكل مبا من خلال المطالب التي
قدمت نحن لا ننسى ان من ضمن المطالب اخراج
القاعده العسكريه التركيه فبالتالي
الاتراك معنيون بالازمه الخليجيه وليسوا
طرفا اجنبيا عنها
لكن يعني بما ان الاتفاقيات لا يمكن النظر
فيها من طرف واحد وانما من طرفين بحسب
القانون الدولي فال الاتراك يجب ان يكونوا
موجودين في هذه الازمه الاتراك لم ياتوا
فقط لهذه سالتيني عن ما افضت اليه الزياره
لم ياتوا فقط في اطار الازمه الخليجيه
وانما هناك ملفات متبادله بين البلدين تم
مناقشته اليوم بعضها ملفات اقليميه وبعضها
اشياء بينيه ومما تولد في اعتقادي ما
سيكون في المستقبل القريب عن مناورات
قريبه بين قطر وتركيا وامريكا مناورات
عسكريه بين البلدان الثلاثه قطر وتركيا
وامريكا قطر وتركيا وامريكا قريبا ستكون
الان يجري الاعداد لها لكنها ستكون في
المستقبل القريب لكن هذا ما يعني ان السيد
اردوغان لم يساهم في محاوله دفع عمليه
الوساطه الكويتي للامام لكن اعتقد ان
السيد اردوغان ينظر يعني لا ينظر لاطراف
الازمه الخليجيه كانها كتله واحده وانما
يفرق بين الطرف السعودي والطرف الاماراتي
ولهذا لم يزر الامارات بطبيعه الحال
العلاقه يعني يمكن اقل ما يمكن ان توصف به
العلاقه التركيه الاماراتيه بانها علاقه
باهته لكن في الطرف المقابل العلاقه بين
السعوديه وتركيا هناك مجلس تنسيقي على
اعلى المستويات بين تركيا وال المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وهناك يعني تنسيق عالي
بين البلدين هناك قوات عسكريه السعوديه في
في تركيا فبالتالي اعتقد ان اردوغان قد
يفكر في سيناريو حل ثنائي بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقطر ما مدى احتماليه
نجاح هذا السيناريو المهم انه احتمال وارد
واعتقد ان السيد اردوغان يعمل في هذا
الاطار ا شعبان قردش اردوغان قال للصحفيين
بان القاعده التركيه في قطر لن تجري
مناقشتها لا في السعوديه ولا في الكويت
ولكن طبعا بطبيعه الحال قال نقشت في قطر
هل نفهم رساله ما من من هذا
التاكيد في الواقع بهذا التصريح اعتقد ان
الرئيس
اردوغان يعكس وجود التغيير في الموقف
السعودي في هذه الازمه
وكما بداوا ب 13 طلبا في البدايه واحد
الفقرات كانت اغلاق القاعده التركيه في
قطر ولكن بمرور الزمن نجد ان هناك تغيير
في السياسه السعوديه ظهرت فكره المبادئ
السته وهو وهما لم لم تطرحه السعوديه
كالشرط بالنسبه للقاعده العسكريه وبالتالي
ف وان هذا
التغيير واذا لم يحصل تاكيد على ذلك اثناء
زياره اردوغان للسعوديه
فان ذلك يعني ضمنا ان الجانب السعودي
فعلا يعترف ويقبل بالوجود التركي في قطر
الا لو كان هناك اي ق قلق السعودي بالنسبه
للقاعده لرفع واثار الموضوع مباشره مع
الرئيس اردوغان وهم لم يفعلوه وبالتالي
فهذا يعني انه ضمنا هم يقبلون الوضع
الحالي فيما يتعلق بالقاعده التركيه في
قطر هل هو تغيير ام تسليم
الخساره في الواقع ان هذا جزء من التطور
العام الذي حصل في موقف الدول الاربعه في
هذه الازمه منذ بدايتها بدايه يونيو
حزيران وفي البدايه كان قد وضعوا طلبات
شديده وكبيره على على الجانب القطري ولكن
بمرور الوقت ومع الموقف التركي الذي ايد
وقف خلف قطر واضافه الى بعض الاطراف
الاقليميه الاخرى تحاول الوساطه والاطراف
الدوليه الاخرى التي
ايضا وقفت خلف قطر وادتها وبالتالي هذا
ادى الى تغيير في سياسه تلك الدول الاربعه
ليس فقط ما يتعلق بالقاعده العسكريه
التركيه بل في حول قضايا اخرى وهذا حسب
فهمي يعني ويعكس حقيقه ان ان الدول
الاربعه كانت في البدايه تطالب تبالغ في
مطالبها وبحيث لم تحظى باي دعم من اي طرف
اقليمي او طرف دولي اما الان فيبدو انه قد
خففوا
او
طلباتهم والان هناك اشاره الى المقاطعه
الى لقطر فقط دكتور باعتقادك وعلى يدي
اردوغان استوعبت السعوديه بان الخطوه التي
كانت اتخذت كانت خطوه خاطئه بحق الجميع
بحقها هي ايضا هو فيما يتعلق بالاعتقاد
السعودي اعتقد ان الخطا كان جليا منذ
المرحله الاولى حينما كانت هي الفكره تقوم
على صدمه القطريين ولذلك هم فعلوا اكبر ما
يمكن ان يفعل من البدايه يعني لم يتدرج في
التصعيد وانما فعلوا اكبر شيء ثم بعد ذلك
حينما صمد القطريون طوال هذه المده راوا
ان القضيه ليست كما كانوا يتصورون والان
اعتقد ان مرحله التصعيد انتهت من مرحله من
اجتماع القاهره الي حدث الان مرحله البحث
عن اليات التشفيه اردوغان اعتقد جاء لدفع
هذه الاليات ولبحث هذه الاليات راينا قبل
قليل تصريحه فيما يتعلق بان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يجب ان يكون لها الدور
الاكبر في حل الازمه قال ذلك قبل ان يصل
هذا شيء جيد لماذا لان لانه يريد ان ينقل
السعوديه من طرف مجرد طرف من اطراف النزاع
الى دور القائد الذي يساعد على الحل يساعد
على الحل ويفضي الى حل بين دول الخليجيه
وهذا هو المنطق لان الان السعوديه ان
الخصم التقليدي وان التحدي الاكبر اقليميا
هو ايران طيب في ظل هذا التشرذم الخليجي
وفي ظل معاداه تركيا من قبل بعض دول
الخليج كيف باي اليه ممكن ان تواجه ايران
اعتقد ان التحالف بين تركيا والسعوديه هو
تحالف مصيري لا يمكن الا ان يكون اذا
كانوا يعتقدون فعلا ان ايران هي التحدي
الاقليمي الاكبر لان بدون تركيا اليوم
العراق كانت معنا سابقا حينما كان صدام
حسين موجود مع الخليج قديما والخليج كله
وقف مع صدام ومع ذلك ما استطاعوا على
ايران وفي ذاك الوقت كانت ايران في غ
الضعف في بدايه الثوره وكان الجيش متفكك
الان في ظل اعاده التوازن الايراني وفي ظل
العراق في صف ايران وفي ظل ان الخليج
متشرد وفي ظل عداوه تركيا ماذا بقي من
اليات يواجههم بها ما يعتقدون انه هو
التحدي الاقليمي لاكبر لان الان لماذا
نقول ما يعتقدون بانه الخصم الاكبر لانهم
هم يدعون ان الخصم او التحدي الاقليمي
الاكبر يتمثل في ايران لكن عمليا لا نرى
اي شيء يثبت ذلك عمليا نرى كل شي من صالح
ايران يعني تخليهم عن الملف الس الملف
العراقي الملف اليمني حتى الان شعال ازمه
خليجيه مفتعله من قبل فبركات كما راينا في
البدايه على ماذا يدل كله يدل على تقويه
الموقف الايراني ولذلك لا اعتقد ان
الايرانيين منذ سقوط صدام حسين فرحوا بشيء
كما فرحوا بهذه الازمه
الخليجيه ولذلك اعتقد اردوغان كل ما يفعله
الان محاوله لاعاده الدور السعودي الى ما
ينبغي ان يكون عليه دور القياده للمشهد
الخليجي وقطر منذ البدايه والى اليوم والى
خطاب سمو الامير قبل يومين دعت الى الحوار
بشكل مطلق في حين ل لم نجد من الاطراف
الاخرى من يدعو الى الحوار بل بالعكس
وجدنا من يفهم دعوه سمو الامير الى الحوار
على انها اغلاقه للحوار كما راينا وزير
الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه في الامارات انور
قرقاش يقول بانها اغلاقه للحوار في حين
نجد اليوم الفرنسيين يشكرون الموقف القطري
على فتح باب الحوار يعني الفرنسيون يفهمون
الدعوه فرنسيون غوتيرس ولافروف روف كذلك
لكن في المقابل لا نجد الاخوه الاشقاء
يفهمون مثل هذا الذي فهمه الانسان الغريب
في فيما يتعلق بال
ام شعبان قردش مولود تشاويش اغلو قال ان
بلاده موقف بلاده من الازمه هو ان ضروره
رفع الحصار قبل مناقشه اي مطالب هل الجانب
التركي باعتقادك لمس ايضا تطورا في هذا
الاتجاه حتى قال ما قاله وزير الخارجيه
التركي
منذ
البدايه كان موقف تركيا في هذه
الازمه ينص على انه لابد من حل الازمه على
اساس مبادئ الانصاف والعداله وان الطلبات
منذ البدايه والاجراءات المطبقه منذ
البدايه لم تكن عادله ابتداء وبالتالي اذا
اذا كنا نسعى باخلاص وحقيقه لى حل لابد ان
الامور وهذا هو التفكير التركي فهذه الدول
الاربعه اذا كانت جاده الدول الاربعه في
البحث عن حل وارد ان تكون قطر مبادره فلا
بد ان يفرض البيئه وال المناخ المناسب
لذلك واعتقد ان وزير الخارجيه قد اكد على
ذلك وثانيا وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالتغير الذي
في موقف الدول او الاطراف
الدوليه كلها تسير نفس الاتجاه فهي الدول
الخارجيه ايضا تدعو الى اجراءات مشابهه من
قبل الدول الاربعه التي تفرض
الحصار اشكرك وصلت الفكره اختم مع دكتور
نايف دكتور هل نحن في مرحله تبريد ام
باتجاه الحل يعني ورفع الحصار ام ام يعني
ستاتيكو هو الوضع الان افضل الوضع الان
حاليا افضل والنبره السياسيه اهد واعتقد
ان الضغط الان الكبير على دول مجلس
التعاون ليس ضغطا سياسيا ولا ضغطا
اقتصاديا اعتقد السياسيين يمكن ان يجلسوا
بمعزل عن بعض لمده طويله وكذلك لا يوجد
ضغط اقتصادي على دول الخليج بان تعود الان
في هذه الحاله لكن هناك ضغط شعبي كبير
بحكم ان الشعوب لم تعتد مثل هذا النزاع
نفوس محتقنه يعني هناك يعني علاقات
تاريخيه واجتماعيه قويه بين بين دول مجلس
التعاون وشعوب مجلس التعاون لا يمكن ان
تفك بهذه الطريقه ممكن هذه الشعوب تصبر
شهر شهرين على الازمه ثلاثه اشهر لكن بعد
ذلك هناك تذمر كبير يعني والاخطر من ذلك
ما هو باعتقادي ان اكبر كارثه تهدد من
وراء استمرار الازمه الخليجيه هو تحول
الخصوم السياسيه بين دول الخليج الى ثقافه
شعبيه بمعنى يعني ثقافه شعبيه وليس مجرد
مرحله مجرد موقف سياسي اختلافي عابر بمعنى
الاحقا الان في خصومه بين قطر مثلا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه لكن هذه
الخصومه قد ينظر لها علىها موقف عابر لكن
قد تتحول الى ثقافه شعبيه بمعنى ان الشعب
القطري يجد ان المملكه خصم سياسي يعيشها
كثقافة
حرب ضد معارضيها في ليبيا فما هي خيارات
تعقب المسؤولين عن تلك الجرائم وكيف يؤثر
على محاولات تحقيق مصالحه في هذا البلد
هذا ما يبحثه جلال شهده في الملف الثاني
من
الحصاد